et je fais appel à vous pour nous aider
à protéger notre population y compris
les musulmans
Ukrainiens avec moi ici présent
l'honorable Mustapha djamilaf le leader
de la communauté de tatar en Crimée
et des indigènes des indigènes de
l'Ukraine il vivent en Crimée et c'est
le centre de la culture musulmane et
pendant des décennies les Tatars en
Crimée étaient et devrait rester une
partie intégrante de la communauté
musulmane du monde entier et
malheureusement les lacrymen c'était la
première partie à souffrir de
l'occupation russe et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui la plupart d'entre eux ils
sont victimes de la répression
la réponse de l'expiration nous avons
déjà une expérience positive avec
l'Arabie Saoudite en ce qui concerne
la libération de notre population de nos
individus nous nous citoyens capturés
par la Russie et même si les peuples
arabes et si dans ce sommet on peut être
à regarder différents par rapport à la
guerre sur notre dans notre pays je suis
confiant que nous pouvons tous nous unir
et unir nos forces pour sauver ceux qui
sont dans les prisons en russe
malheureusement certains dans le monde
et certains parmi vous ici détourne le
regard par rapport à ces annexations et
légales et à ses actions et donc je fais
appel ici à tous pour regarder d'une
manière très honnête et ce malgré les
pressions des Russes et je voudrais
remercier le royaume de l'Arabie
Saoudite et la majorité d'entre vous
pour votre soutien à notre position sur
la scène internationale ainsi que la
Charte des Nations Unies chers
participants vos populations savent déjà
que les Ukrainiens c'est un peuple de
paix et en 2021
nous avons
exprimer à vous populations et aux
populations au peuple de l'Arabie
Saoudite de Oman de Bahreïn de des
émirats par rapport à l'Ukraine et je
suis heureux
que vous taurise ont pu visiter notre
capital qui est et voir sa beauté ainsi
que la beauté de nos montagnes et je
suis confiante un jour vous peuples vont
revenir pour visiter notre Crimée la
Crimée qui est au crinienne libre à ce
moment de l'agression en russe nous
populations entretiennent des liens
d'éducation et il y a des dizaines de
milliers d'étudiants et d'étudiants
arabes dont nous universités chaque
année et c'est en honneur pour nous que
les enfants du Maroc de l'Egypte de la
Jordanie de l'Irak du Liban et de
l'Algérie et de la Libye et de la
Tunisie ont été en Ukraine pour
poursuivre leur éducation avec vous
nous avons réalisé une tâche parmi les
plus honorables au monde c'est la
sécurité alimentaire l'Ukraine
exporte le blé et d'autres produits
agricoles à vos pays et nous sommes
heureux et nous saluons les
investissements les investissements des
pays arabes et du Qatar dans nos
infrastructures portuaires d'abord la
pandémie et le terrible virus et ensuite
l'agression russe
on ira qu'on Afghanistan tous ceux qui
rajoutent avec leurs agressions à la
souffrance des populations
ceux qui veulent ramener les jours
évoluent et ramener le passé et renier
l'indépendance des nations tout
agression est contre le monde entier et
je
suis d'accord et je tends la main à tous
ceux qui veulent nous rejoindre sur le
chemin vers la justice et un appel pour
mettre fin à cette guerre et je prends
l'exemple la sécurité
alimentaire même quand la guerre est
chez nous en fait tout ce qu'on peut
pour être pour s'assurer que les autres
populations vont survivre on a lancé
l'initiative de la mer Noire et
partiellement on a réussi à contourner
le blocus russe de ne pas cela à amener
plus de stabilité au marché alimentaire
et à aider beaucoup de pays y compris
certains pays de la Ligue arabe et notre
formule de paix cela en fait partie et
ainsi que le retour de tout ceux qui ont
été déportés et tous les prisonniers
chaque
délégation avec un document dans votre
langue nous avons 10 points de notre
formule s'il vous plaît choisissez les
points que vous considérez comme des
points appropriés et je serai très
reconnaissant à ce parmi vous qui vont
choisir comment sauver les gens en
Russie et les captives et les
prisonniers en Russie
vient à un moment où nous devons
continuer à continuer à lutter pour la
liberté et la souveraineté des nations
je vous souhaite la paix et je vous
invite à coopérer directement avec notre
pays
sans d'autres intermédiaires
et que nos pays puissent travailler
ensemble de manière coordinaire voilà
donc on a pu écouter un extrait de la
prise de parole de volody mirzelinski le
président ukrainien depuis le sommet de
la Ligue arabe à Jedda en Arabie
Saoudite bienvenue à ceux qui nous
rejoignent sur France 24 c'est donc l'un
des grands rendez-vous diplomatiques de
ce jour le sommet de la Ligue arabe on
en parle aujourd'hui avec Bilal Tarabay
bonjour Bilal la venue visiblement
surprise de
volodiainski à Jedda que retenir tout
d'abord de cette de cette prise de
parole à la venue tout à fait surprise
vous avez absolument raison de
volodimeers zellenski à jeda alors en
retenir plusieurs choses d'abord
volodymeerselenski comme à son habitude
lorsqu'il va plaider la cause de
l'Ukraine dans un pays étranger il
trouve des sujets qui sont proches des
préoccupations qui font des références
directes au pays en question là il est
en Arabie Saoudite où se trouve la
Mecque si certaines personnes l'avaient
oublié au sommet de la Ligue arabe et
donc il parle des Tatars cette minorité
musulmane en Ukraine donc les Tatars qui
sont en Crimée qui a été annexé par par
la Russie en 2014 il parle aussi de la
diaspora arabe qui est parti dans
certains étudiants sont partis faire
leurs études en Ukraine il a cité les
étudiants algériens il part aussi de de
la souffrance liée aux guerres et il
rappelle à l'île garab à quel point ces
pays couvrent des régions qui sont
concernées par des guerres depuis la
depuis des décennies il a cité les
guerres en Syrie en Libye en Irak au
Soudan y compris en Afghanistan donc ça
c'est comme toujours avec
volodyberselenski pour pour créer de
l'empathie ensuite sur un deuxième plan
il a cherché à s'adresser ce qu'on
appelle le sud global dont lui-même
c'est bien qu'il y a une forme de désint
pourrait voir d'indifférence avec cette
guerre en Ukraine qui est perçue comme
une guerre entre européen donc il a
rappelé que la guerre avait beau avoir
lieu effectivement sur le sol européen
en Ukraine qu'elle entraînait par
ricochet une insécurité alimentaire qui
concerne au premier chef c'est CPI du
Sud global il veut aussi
par sa présence en Arabie Saoudite faire
valoir ses arguments auprès de Mohamed
Ben Salman qui lui-même par un effet
domino peut éventuellement les faire
valoir auprès de la Chine merci beaucoup
Bilal et on rejoint sur place notre
envoyé spécial à Jedda Douglas Herbert
bonjour Douglas c'est devenu surprise
donc de Vladimir Zelinski éclipse en
quelque sorte le retour annoncé de
Bachar el-Assad au sein enfin sur la
scène diplomatique arabe on sait que ça
a suscité un tollé à l'international
notamment auprès des organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme c'est donc
l'Ukraine qui a dominé les échanges de
ce matin et Mohamed Ben Salman dans son
discours tout à l'heure a même proposé
d'être médiateur dans dans cette guerre
il y a zzki qui fait éruption dans la
salle et c'est plus Bachar Assad sur les
projecteurs alors c'était vraiment un
tournement comme on a dit spectaculaire
tu as le planning de ce sommet et le
fait que MBS a voulu saluer avant
pachadeinski Sandy l'homme sur l'acte de
d'équilibriste si vous voulez que joue
en ce moment Mohamed Ben Salman il veut
à la fois être le rassembleur de la
famille arabe et en cela il a un c'est
lui qui a invité Bachar Assad rejoindre
la Ligue après 12 ans d'exclusion mais
en même temps et c'est peut-être un clin
d'oeil à la diplomatie des Américains il
a invité c'est lui le même Mohamed Ben
Salman qui est invité Zelinski à venir à
la même salle que Bachar Assad alors
c'était vraiment un moment
extraordinaire et ça rend ce sommet
beaucoup plus intéressant tant sur le
plan politique que sur le plan
géopolitique et diplomatique et ça va
peut-être rendre quelque chose apporter
quelque chose à Zelenski à laver d'une
vache contre offensive attendue contre
la Russie merci beaucoup Douglas pour
ces précisions depuis Jeddah